two billionaires two trips to space
nine days apart they are ushering in a
new era
of private commercial space travel
here's how the two space trips compare
from takeoff
to landing
this was virgin galactic's fourth trip
to space with crew members while blue
origin is heading out for the first time
with humans aboard
i really want you to come with me would
you are you serious i am
virgin galactic's suborbital
rocket-powered craft gets dropped off in
the air by a larger craft called vms
eve then released release release
release
clean release ignition
good rocket motor burn while blue
origin's new shepard rocket is launched
from the ground
virgin galactic reached an altitude of
53 miles
blue origin will soar to about 66 miles
richard branson is going to be going
into space we can debate
where the line of space is the karman
line is a measure that attempts to mark
the end of earth's atmosphere
but it's not a fixed height not everyone
considers branson's destination to be
space
[Music]
in fact we're the only private company
that's taken private citizens
up into space come back and been
recognized by the us government
as private astronauts so yes we are
taking you into space
[Music]
virgin galactic's flight lasted about 90
minutes in total
while blue origin's flight is expected
to last about 11 minutes
one a view oh my goodness
passengers will experience three or so
minutes of weightlessness during which
people can float and enjoy the views
virgin galactic's rocket plane glides to
a landing on a runway
similar to old nasa space shuttles blue
origin's automated capsules
parachute to the desert floor similar to
the russian soyuz capsules
in kazakhstan
both companies plan to take paying
customers to space
virgin galactic plans to offer flights
to well-heeled customers in 2022.
virgin has also said its technology
could be adapted to slash flight times
anywhere on the planet to just four or
five hours
blue origin has its own plans for a base
on the moon's south pole
bezos has said he envisions millions of
people living and working in space
and that lowering the cost of space
travel with rockets that can be reused
like airplanes
is the first step
you